Whenever you send a search request to Google, the server
actually does something really, really clever. Before the server even
knows what the search results are, it immediately returns the
header of the page, which is what you see here, and
this header is the same for all users. This allows
the browser to start processing the response and begin constructing
the DOM incrementally, and potentially even render the header. Then,
once the search results are ready, the rest of the HTML
arrives, and the browser parses that and displays the content. As
you can see, the browser doesn't have to wait for all of
the HTML to arrive before processing, and neither should your server.
In fact, returning partial HTML can be a really nice performance optimization.
>> Incremental HTML delivery. Very clever. Out of curiosity, how do
the engineers at Google measure and optimize the performance of their pages?
>> Believe it or not, they all
use the same tools, Chrome developer tools
and mobile debugging. Let me show you.